qu'est ce qui s'est passé fabrice à laon
il sait absolument pas rien passé sinon
on est sur un put à cliquer un titre
absolument détestable du canard enchaîné
le canard enchaîné m'a appelé en me
disant parlez moi de la faire de jules
est ce que vous laissez pas ce que
j'aurais répondu non je ne connais pas
la sphère de jules c'est pas moi qui les
traitaient et j'aurais donné le numéro
de mon associé qu'était aux états unis
effectivement qui a traité le dossier
donc le canard enchaîné acheter un
article enfin vous avez dit je n'ai pas
traité le dossier alors après ils sont
partis sur la vidéo est est ce que vous
savez pourquoi c'est parce que j'ai pas
traiter le dossier parce que j'étais
occupé à traiter le dossier de la vidéo
qui n'est pas le même dossier et lorsque
vous entendez la vidéo vous comprenez
que ce n'est pas le même dossier dans le
dossier de la vidéo les deux parents
n'étaient pas d'accord le médecin
traitant n'était pas d'accord nous
avions un effet secondaire documenté et
nous avions un jeune d'une trentaine
d'années également le seul point commun
c'est que c'était un jeune d'une
trentaine d'années je me suis évertué a
essayé de l'expliquer au canard enchaîné
que ce dossier là c'est moi qui l'ait
traité et j'ai même pas eu à le traiter
puisque le garçon est décédé finalement
deux jours plus tard donc je n'ai pas eu
à le traiter mais je me suis évertué à
essayer d'expliquer canard enchaîné que
je n'avais pas traiter le dossier dit de
jules c'était mon associé qu'il l'avait
traité et c'était à elle qu'il fallait
parler pourquoi est ce qu'ils se sont
pas parlés ça moi ça me concerne mais
s'attend l'état en appelant à ne pas
rentrer en contact et ça ça vaut une
plainte avec onction de partie civile
devant le doyen des juges d'instruction
pour diffamation parce que déjà le titre
le titre c'est plus tactique l'avocat
anti passe division paralyser un hôpital
alors ça quand vous lisez l'article déjà
vous comprenez on parle de tout à fait
autre chose mais voilà maintenant quand
effectivement la famille qui m'accuse je
sais pas très bien pourquoi elle
m'accuse mais c'est pas grave après la
pause actuelle mais je ne sais pas ce
que vous appelez la famille non mais
d'abord la famille ne peut pas m'appeler
s'il est ce qui s'est passé dans cette
affaire pour ce que j'en ai compris
puisque ce n'est pas moi qui ai traité
le dossier mais évidemment je me suis
renseigné depuis en fait qu'à un litige
familial avec d'un côté la famille du
père de l'autre la famille de la mère et
si j'ai bien compris
nous aurions été saisie par l'une des
deux parties qui n'est pas donc celle
qui nous accusent maintenant pourquoi
est-ce que je suis accusé ça je lis
niort pour le coup ça je ne sais pas
mais en fait c'est pas grave à ce que je
sois accusé par la famille si vous
voulez si c'est important de faire leur
deuil et s'attend à accuser quelqu'un
parfois on accuse de médecins d'autres
l'avocat c'est pas grave l'enquêté je
comprends cette cette souffrance et
cette presse et cité de faire son deuil
mais ensuite l'objectivité des faits que
n'a pas rappelé le canard enchaîné on
est face à une difficulté si vous voulez
c'est que maintenant j'en suis arrivé à
un point où je me dis que je vais
accorder des interviews à la condition
de pouvoir les enregistrer alors la
famille sera là dans un instant donc on
aura leur version o'sheas r&d m divisés
c'est un peu facile de votre part de
dire c'est pas moi c'est mon associé
vous avez transmis le dossier à votre
associé à votre cabinet c'est vous no
comment ma question à l'éclair est ce
que vous n'avez pas profité de la
faiblesse d'une famille pour faire
passer vos convictions contre le pass
contre le vaccin comment
comment vous aurez s'est passé mais en
essayant d'appeler l'hôpital où votre
associé et son retard d un processus de
sédation ça c'est très précis dans le
canard enchaîné vous avez été mandatée
24 heures par la mer et vous en avez
profité pour appeler l'hôpital j'ai été
mauvais ça c'est vrai alors d'abord je
veux dire j'ai pas parlé d'une affaire
couverts par le secret ah ouais mais bon
ya pas de oui mais excusez moi
oui mais ça c'est trop facile ah non si
vous voulez je veux bien parler du
traitement médiatique de la faire mais
je ne parlerai pas de la faire à dos les
larbins la famille avant par les
donnerai pas le ciel vous mais moi je
suis couvert par le secret et jusqu'à
nouvel ordre je vais respecter la loi et
je vais respecter la déontologie ça
c'est le premier point mais le deuxième
point interrogez vous sur un point
gilles l'avocat il a agi de sa propre
initiative ou quelqu'un demande à temps
il a été quasi il a été saisi les
saisies donc je connais un train de
m'expliquer il a été saisi par écrit
nous dans mon cabinet on est toujours
saisi par écrit et la limite des mandats
elle est donnée par écrit on ne fait que
ce qu'on nous dit de faire pas un crime
et les c6 pourquoi marine pourquoi pas
comprendre saisie pour faire ce que nous
a dit de faire croire
gestion si effectivement on a écrit à
l'hôpital c'est parce qu'on a été saisie
pour crise à l'hôpital dans le papier du
canard ne pas pas vous dire en gros que
vous et appelé l'hôpital pour cesser la
sédation yin weidong que c'est bien ce
que c'est parce qu'on comprend rien ce
qui expliquerait le cas de sanofi
explique le canard ces consultants si je
comprends bien nous aurions pris notre
téléphone pour appeler l'hôpital faisant
arrêter la citation et oui maintenant
j'ai deux questions
lui ai donc j'aimerais prolonger la
souffrance attentif de l'homme devait un
jour j'ai testé reprocher j'ai dit dieu
qui ne va pas d'imagés de 4e division à
prolonger l'univers de nos moyens juste
question avec ça premièrement donc on se
serait mis à appeler l'hôpital et donc
sur un coup de fil et un c'est quoi la
prochaine étape on l'a menacé des
instituts si jamais tu arrêtes pas les
siens mais tu nous écoute pas on vient
avec un flingue c'est ça la prochaine
étape je vous rappelle qu'on est une
profession réglementée donc déjà
téléphoné ça sert à rien vois pas
l'intérêt de téléphoner pourquoi on
aurait téléphoné on a aussi on a fait
quelque chose c'est écrit et pourquoi je
dis si parce que je m'évertue à vous
rappelez nous dit c'est mon cabinet mais
non c'est pas vrai c'est notre cabinet
c'est à dire que c'est le vous semblez
pas comprendre quelque chose je suis
gérant de ce cabinet mais j'ai une
associée qu'à acheter des parts sociales
et qu'elle son portefeuille de clients
c'est pas moi c'est elle a passé une fin
enfin c'est une blague ou quoi
excusez moi vous imaginez moi j'ai un
domaine qui est le mien puis à mon
associé effectivement à son portefeuille
de clients c'est mon associé qui gère ce
dossier moi j'ai une question bête
pourquoi le canard n'est pas entre en
contact avec elle à ce que c'est vous le
mets sur vidéo pas d'alerter la vidéo
voilà la vidéo oui parlons la vidéo 1
est ce que je m'évertue essayer de vous
expliquer que cette vidéo correspondait
à notre dossier pour lequel j'ai même
été mandatée par écrit encore une fois
le cas normaux dit non c'est pas vrai
bon bah écoutez si au bout d'un moment
non c'est pas vrai et vous avez juste à
tubes et bien si vous avez effectivement
toutes les réponses c'est pas la peine
de poser les questions quoi elle va je
vais vous dire sans l'autre on discutera
le cas du procès en diffamation c'est
tout mais répondait à notre question
s'il vous plaît m vous avez été mandaté
pour quoi on a été mandaté pour
effectivement précisément et bien
interrompre pas interrompre n'a mandaté
les mandataires mais voilà voyez vous
l'avait dit pour un de ces nations pour
finir sa phrase alors si vous voulez
fêter la mission ne log vous pouvez
faire tout seul du tout mais le fait est
que nous on a été réaliste on a été
mandaté pour une tâche précise d'accord
cette tâche précise inclus est
manifestement effectivement d'intervenir
une partie de la famille n'était pas
d'accord avec le processus d'arrêt des
soins si la sphère vincent lambert la
pierre vincent lambert vous avez deux
parties de la famille qui se déchire et
une partie a saisi un avocat et l'autre
a saisi un avocat alors donc une partie
de la famille a saisi votre super pour
justement intervenir absolue et bientôt
la dernière heure la soeur vainqueur la
soeur de jules qui est décédé et là ce
soir elle voulait s'entretenir avec
fabrice di vizio merci série 7 avec nous
applaudissements pour elle merci
merci d'être là merci d'éclairer je sais
que vous venez d'arriver en plus oui
vraiment mais voilà elle vient d'arriver
c'est juste fait équiper rapidement iris
racontez-nous votre version de
l'histoire qui concernent votre frère
c'est parfait jobin chronologiquement
non non non longo ouais en gros pour
vous votre résumé avis vous résumer à
moi ses confrères a fait un avc le 25
février il y avait 30 ans il avait 30
ans 33 ans exactement
donc il s'est fait opérer il a été
transféré à marseille après retourner
avignon et est donc le 19 avril la
décision de le débrancher a été pris ça
a été accepté en accord avec le corps
médical jules je le devrais patients le
vendredi 22 de la semaine qui suit
le mercredi 20 avril à 8h17 la fameuse
vidéo et publiée sur twitter à 11h30
l'hôpital reçoit le fax du cabinet de
division et du docteur bernstein
demandant l'arrêt du protocole de
sédation de mon frère
la décision est donc voilà le premier
désistement de madame brown qui était
censé être votre cliente vous avez dit
quelque chose madame d'importants la wii
le courrier de qui de madame brand a été
sans cesse vous avez tout fuyante là
vous venez tout dire donc compris vous
mets tout dire vous venez de dire qu'en
fait mon cabinet je comprends que vous
en preniez à moi mais mon cabinet vous
venez de dire qui a été saisi par qui
et c'est qu'ils me rendent la mère de
joie là d'accord qui s'est dessaisi le
jour même voilà s'est dessaisi le jour
où ça veut dire qu'ils intentent les de
vous contacter pendant deux semaines à
madame je veux dire je parlerai pas
savoir si une nouvelle de votre part
donner moi je juge sur ce point je vais
quand même vous décevoir mais je vous
dirai pas ce qui s'est passé dans cette
affaire s'agissant de madame brand parce
que vous n'êtes pas madame brown et je
ne rends compte qu'à ma cliente et je
suis vraiment la solution me suis je
vous l'avais pas rencontrée donc là je
ne comprends pas encore une fois moi je
dis non c'est pas marrant tu oses tu
m'appeler son associé qu'à gérer le
dossier l'amendé alors donc pour ces la
maman de pulls wii qui vous a saisi oui
pour arrêter le processus pour continuer
à séduire et
tracter le journal et est ce que nous
avons poursuivi quelque chose madame
c'est important que vous le sachiez vous
envoyer plusieurs ds que nous avons
poursuivi quelque chose vous n'avez vous
ne nous avez plus répondu n'y a ni
mialon qu'il est madame j'ai pas à vous
répondre et l'hôpital mais madame j'ai
pas mal oui à l'intrus climat damian
long mais la dame m'a clients ma
personne madame ma cliente je vous dirai
pas effectivement ce qui s'est dit ou
pas dit avec nous mais pour l'instant
c'est pas ma cliente qui me reprochent
quelque chose ou qu'ils reprochent
quelque chose à ma cliente c'est mon
adversaire qui retrouve quelque chose
pardonnez moi madame mais vous êtes nos
adversaires dans cette affaire donc vous
comprenez que je peux pas m'en
entretenir avec vous plus avant sur ce
dossier vous comprenez qu'effectivement
je comprends votre peine et je comprends
la nécessité que vous ayez de vous en
prendre à mon cabinet je le reçois
simplement vous pouvez comprendre que si
vous avez un problème avec madame brand
c'est madame brand qu'il faut voir pas
moi et pourquoi madame brown elle ne se
plaint pas alors madame brown n'est pas
en capacité physique et morale de venir
se plaindre à l'heure actuelle et je
pense que
veux m'excuser
je pense que je pense que je pense que
vous êtes vous n'avez pas à rien à faire
dans cette histoire d'accord suite au
fait ce que votre tweet a été publié en
parlant de mon frère madame non votre
tour ne parlait pas
s'il vous plaît c'est important vous mes
coups de pied sur le twitt parce que le
canard enchaîné a vraiment raconter
n'importe quoi je vous explique ce qui
s'est passé et et et je ne sais pas si
je suis autorisé à le faire si je le
suis je vous montrerai volontiers sous
réserve d'anonymat n'y a pas pas de
jules qui veut aller je voulais pas
montrer ma gueule altérée si je suis là
je suis désolé je suis vraiment très mal
de tête
écoutez monsieur division mercredi comme
a dit ma fille le tweet à zinder tente
le truc a dit 30 à partir de là c'était
fini pour juin c'était fini oui monsieur
la peur du scandale je vais pas pour
l'hôpital c'est sûr maintenant je vous
ai appelé ce jour même monsieur je te
perds attend déjà pelé ventre voilà
standard ce jour même une fois je suis
tombé sur la tête en dari oui elle m'a
dit appeler cet après midi mais le
standard le monsieur division l'après
midi personne répond monsieur écoutez
j'ai rappelé le lendemain j'ai eu vent
secrétaire votre standard nice voilà je
lui ai réitéré vous avez reçu des mails
des désistements avec les pièces
d'identité sur les photocopies vous
savez très bien que
le style est d'identifier de madame
cathy le répète c'est un nom parce que
l' écoute j'ai nommé je vous parle c'est
vrai finir donc alors comme ça
explique-t-il je vous ai appelé oui mais
ça je vous atteler je vais pas vous
parler lui que meirieu tout logiquement
le jeudi qu'est-ce que vous êtes venu le
vent body excusez moi et après vous
m'avez appelé le lundi ce que je vous ai
rappelé le lundi faisait appeler pour
vous direz vous m'avez appelé le lundi
10 ans exactement quand j'ai mis le
lundi j'ai eu en scène tout est le vrai
numéro de monsieur di vizio et je suis
allé voir mon ex-femme qui
personnellement s'est désisté au
téléphone avec vous monsieur résultat
des courses monsieur mon fils il a eu
son deuxième de maxi nation deuxième en
septembre oui petit fils qu'il a eus
sont investis dans un hôpital
psychiatrique en février mon fils est
dans le coma depuis le début de la
guerre nous nous savions que il n'y
avait pas d'espoir parce que si vous
vous renseignez quelqu'un qui a une
trachéo si on ne peut pas l'enlever y va
je le dis à tout le monde comme ça au
moins c'est clair 1 voilà alors les
antilles vax
monsieur les gens s'appelle moi mon fils
il a le sonos qui commence par chez sa
mère à son nom qui commence par moi j'ai
dit que cc brawn mais moi mon les noms
des gens qui venant de contracter il
commence par h un problème vous je vous
parle monsieur divise si vous établissez
vos mails écouter comprendre vous êtes
un bon cas médiatique qui est
effectivement monsieur division des
programmes à vérifier le langue de m
vous n'avez rien déposé ça dépasse 2
vous déposez sur twitter monsieur
division monsieur dans les tribunes où
est ce que je vais effectivement
monsieur division alors on va à toutes
ces campagnes l'attestation du tribunal
de nîmes puisque ça dépend du tribunal
de lure connaissez dans son coin en
attendant les laissez moi parler il a
semblé je sors après je m'en vais
d'accord je parle dix minutes et je m'en
vais voilà on a une attestation qu'on a
eu le lendemain c'est à dire le jeudi du
tribunal de nîmes commence à monsieur
division n'a rien détourné et pourquoi
je suis là excusez moi monsieur division
et monsieur bergé in aussi puisqu'il est
dans le coup ouais monsieur di vizio il
est l'arrière fond sur les antilles vax
qui est la connaissais même pas 2 juin
dans le coup nous ici ce sont les
raisons que de ses demi-frères messieurs
thibault mentionné monsieur monsieur je
vous dis il ne porte même pas leurs
essieux monsieur division il ya mon
numéro depuis le mercredi cieux va
répondre mais je m'en fous de foot moi
je m'en fous de joie j'explique aux gens
j'explique vous j'ai essayé de vous
joindre présentation je ne pourrais pas
vous permet donc je veux voir si il a
enregistré sur d'ailleurs on avait du
coup de fil de mon fils moi je peux
tomber souffrance tout ce que je dis les
cieux division cieux je peux me prouver
que je donne ma téléphone il mais c'est
fini maintenant je vous dis moi je suis
pas là pour discuter crois qu'il faut
que je suis depuis le dimanche de pâques
à vian fils je comprend huit heures par
jour est allé voir les avocats temps je
vais n'est pas mon fils je suis saoul
vous m'avez rendu tout je vais finir me
dit que j'étais fou tout le monde me dit
que je suis fou vous m'entendez fou
alors vous faites tout vous voulez les
gens qui vous ont contacté je les
connais même pas je sais que mon ex elle
était comme ça qu'est ce qu'elle appelle
élever son fils et le passé votre enfant
et que son mari faisait comme ça mais
les offres pour les ont alors cédé dur
de dur mais je comprends je suis ma ce
qu'ils nous ont fait monsieur de vidéo
mais en tous les cas je pense que c'est
pas du travail d'avocat je voudrais ccc
dollars j'ai écouté voilà maintenant
c'est que je m'en vais
vous poser si vous avez des questions
sur ce qui s'est passé ou ce qui s'est
passé vous posez vous donner à voir les
questions vous vous étiez un peu
compliqué c'est pas fait leurs adieux au
loger tous moi je vais vous garantis
qu'il aurait eu cent fois le temps c'est
de faire marche arrière et les de faire
voir à jour se et vous et que jockey en
tout dix huit mois je vais jouer mais ce
disque merci julien mais pour l'équipe
je ne sais jamais si vous voulez
monsieur merci julien mère parce que je
constate merci jours
première chose quand même c'est que je
respecte profondément la souffrance et
dans ses affaires j'en ai une quinzaine
par an quand même chez moi on en a une
autre reste cependant juniac
et je pense qu'elle se respecte ce
accueille bien sûr d'abord mais monsieur
a dit quelque chose d'intéressant il a
dit je n'ai rien déposé au tribunal
pourquoi je n'ai rien déposé au tribunal
peut-être parce que tout simplement la
personne qui nous avait mandaté nous ad
mandaté tout simplement bat et excusez
moi madame madame je vous répondrais un
chiffre d'affaires l'instant
je veux vous faire comprendre quelque
chose c'est pas contre vous c'est que je
suis soumis au secret professionnel et
que vous n'êtes pas ma cliente même
façon quand votre papa m'a appelé il l'a
très bien dit j'ai refusé de lui parler
parce que je ne peux pas lui parler
c'est mon adversaire je n'ai pas le
droit de le graver on est tous très émus
par ce qu'a dit julien parce que ruth un
mot sur la vidéo juste un mot oui
j'aurais juste que je voudrais juste
expliqué que cette vidéo j'ai retrouvé
quelque chose d'intéressant sur la vidéo
dont vous prêtez calais pour jules je
suis désolé de vous dire que c'est
excusez moi j'ai juste terminer sur ce
point après je vous laisse parler mais
c'est important qu'on comprenne cette
vidéo j'ai été mandaté pour une affaire
qui sans doute à quelque chose de
similaire mais pas tant que ça si vous y
regardez pas tant que ça parce que dans
la sphère donc je vous parle vous aviez
les deux parents et le médecin traitant
qui s'opposaient à l'arrêt des soins
alors c'est un jeune d'une trentaine
d'années également qui lui avait
vraiment fait un avc à la suite de
l'acceptation agréable excusez moi parce
que c'était documenté au dossier médical
c'est comme ça
mais semaine dernière d'amsteg deux
semaines pardon mais madame à la même
période mais si vous voulez ce matin
j'en encore u2 madame
de famille qui se déchire puis sur ces
questions de samedi c'est pour ça que
j'ai commencé pour ça qu emmanuel macron
a dit que le législateur devait
légiférer sur ces questions parce que sa
famille se déchire et enfin laissez moi
vous regardez c'est important que vous
l'entendez
cette vidéo madame ne concernait pas à
jules vous pouvez ne pas me croire mais
moi j'ai retrouvé les mails la famille
qui cook étaient concernés par cette
vidéo vous voulez qu'on médiatise la
faire j'ai les noms elle voulait qu'on
médiatise la faire je me suis opposé
j'ai accepté de faire une vidéo sur
twitter et rien d'autre c'est tout elle
est anonyme et en aucun cas elle ne
concernait je ne vais pas vous dire qui
elle concerne parce que là encore je
suis soumis au secret je compatis à
votre peine mais vous êtes
conflit familial dont hélas je me suis
retrouvé effectivement fin mon cabinet
s'est retrouvé au milieu pas grand chose
d'autre fabrice mois cette question
parce que vous avez des mots très ému
par ce choix on le devient sérieux pas
j'essaie de mettre l'émotion de côté
j'ai quelque chose qui me choque pas
bruno tout ce que vous avez dit et
notamment l'article ce qui me choque
chez vous c'est que vous vous soyez vous
désolidariser de votre associé mais pas
bon c'est tout l'article c'est mon
associé tous donc là vous auriez un
associé qui aimait pas très clean mais
vous vous seriez bien aimable et enfin
je veux dire tout ce qu'on rapproche
c'est vrai ça c'est je suis au courant
de rien n'est pas comme on doit être
associé à merveille tous les peuples se
libèrent choisissent mais je suis
parfaitement solidaire de mon associé à
tu racontes n'importe pas ses jambes au
début mais pas du tout j'ai dit que
c'est mon associé qui a traité le
dossier qu'il faut que je te parle d'un
dossier que je ne connais pas oui mais
mal baisées c'est mon associé mais
est-ce que vous aurez à navteq et pas
très clean cet après midi j'ai une de
mes associés qui est allé plaider un
dossier à la cour est-ce qu'il faut que
je te parle de ce dossier non mais quand
le dossier est dans le canard enchaîné
que visiblement ses moyens vous n'avez
pas d'étendre les vous avez dit c'est
pas bien mais c'est pas moi un truc très
simple alors pourquoi c'est pas votre
associé qui est venu et que c'est vous
qui venez explique que c'est moi qui
suis accusé c'est pourquoi sur le bac
c'est que l'hôpital est la votation la
satire est à ce moment là lors des
séries
le nom de gaz mais c'est non mais c'est
à mon nom mais ces normes et pousse à
mon nom parce que c'est mon cabinet je
veux dire je suis effectivement on a
ironisé webber de la sacem et je suis
solidaire de qui vous voulez c'est pas
le problème dans cette affaire je vais
essayer de résumer une bonne fois pour
toutes sur le fait que je suis tenu au
secret si vous avez un problème madame
je vous invite à faire quelque chose qui
est essentiel et je vous encourage à
faire saisissez l'ordre des avocats
vraiment fait le parce que vis-à-vis de
mon ordre je ne suis pas allé dans
l'émotion l'allemagne
choses vous êtes en conflit familial
monsieur l'a dit monsieur habib lui même
parent qui j'ai été saisi vous savez
madame que j'ai que mon cabinet a été
saisi par écrit et qu'il a été dessaisie
par écrit et à partir du moment où il a
été dessaisi nous ne sommes plus les
avocats n'intervenons plus en fait dans
cette affaire du point mais posez vous
une autre question je voudrais qu'on
s'interroge tous collectivement sur un
point l'hôpital arrêtez les soins fin a
pris une décision thérapeutique sur la
base d'un tweet anonymes qui ne
concernait même pas ce dossier dont il
était aisé de comprendre qui ne
concernait pas c'est ça l'idée en ont
dans l'hôpital a arrêté la procédure
suit à eau mais ils n'ont offert ce de
votre cabinet qui a été reçu au service
réanimation oui pourtant votre nom et à
la vidéo mise sur twitter l'élu dont
madame les deux
meilleurs madame madame et jeudi de
parler avec lui c'est madame madame la
vidéo ne parlait pas de simples prenait
on interrompt pas maintenant madame
déclare madame prenez maintenant groupe
à des soins si vital interrogé son
enfance pour ddv dame je me suis
occasion vous prenez toute la france
pour des débiles je vous ai eus au
téléphone vous m'avez aussi pris pour
une débile si vous voulez mais la belge
qui toute ma famille j'utilisais dit je
ne pouvais pas vous parler madame donc
dans la même journée vous sortez une
vidéo sur twitter par landon monsieur
café où l'on bosse où tu te trompes aux
avc il a l'âge de mon frère willow qui
n'est pas votre frère parce que le
dossier médical le même jour sur wii le
même jour puisque maintenant lien
m'enfin c'est quoi ce look c'est une
vidéo maladroit et avec une mauvaise
groenland est un associé dans les repas
solidaire suis un bon dossier mais c'est
pas faux si moi excusez moi excusez moi
on va essayer de se résumer de 10
secondes parce que là je crois qu'il
faut vraiment un moment donné m de la
rigueur là dedans mon cabinet spécialisé
en droit de la santé il traite en
moyenne entre quatre et cinq dossiers
d'arrêt des soins par trimestre il
s'avère que ce matin là j'ai saisi la
pardonnez moi j'ai été saisi la veille
de ce dossier là dans le prolongement
mon cabinet a également été saisie du
dossier de votre frère point vous avez
droit de pannes problème madame je ne
veux pas je bave je suis pas là ça n'a
pas beaucoup mais c'est pas grave que
mon premier pas en fait j'ai pas me
justifier je suis humain je suis pas
j'ai pas me justifier vous savez moi je
pense moi je suis je devenu chez moi
choquée j'aimerais vous faire comprendre
quelque chose je pense que c'est je
comprends que vous vous en prenez à moi
mais en l'occurrence effectivement si
vous savez en l'espèce moi j'ai été on
au cabinet a été saisi et point à la
ligne et quand il a fait ce qu'on lui a
demandé de faire maintenant vous avez un
conflit familial que je respecte et
vraiment je respecte profondément mes
madame je vous garantis et l'article du
canard enchaîné l'audi vous savez
pourquoi votre frère n'a pas été
débranché tout de suite je vais vous le
dire pourquoi l'article ne dit pas ce
que le comité d'éthique n'avait pas été
saisie or c'est une obligation de saisir
le comité d'éthique c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est l'article qui le dit non parce
que le premier benchikha a dû être
saisie après bon non mais non mairie p 6
mais si tu comprends à venir et je
voudrais vous remercier on était là est
vraiment le témoignage de votre papa
nous a bouleversés et même un fabre ici
et je voudrais juste rappeler la luge et
la cgc pour je le connais pas exactement
qui promet d'embaucher pour lui rendre
hommage et pour faire un sens que ça
cause de exactement soit justiciables
juste ici je jure être jugé pardon il
risque en tout cas j vous avez été
extraordinairement aux explications et
on comprend votre peine et la peine de
votre papa et
on sera là pour vous pour faire avancer
l'histoire époux et elle fait ça aussi
pour que ça se reproduise plus voilà
pour d'autres cartes